it it's it's getting to the point where
the where the debates that are taking
place in congress
are just extensions of these stupid um
status competitions that are taking
place online it's surreal and it's
uh it's highly destructive to democracy
pierre bordeaux
who's a french sociologist now deceased
he was the first to point out that class
social class
is not just a function of one's economic
capital but also of one's accrued
cultural capital and cultural capital is
basically
um the knowledge
and tastes and mannerisms
that are inculcated that allow a person
to
sort of get ahead in a given environment
journalists tend to have a lot of
accumulated cultural capital um
even if they don't have a whole lot of
economic capital your average i don't
know
um junior level new york times writer
this probably
makes a solid middle-class income but
they're not rich um but they have a lot
of cultural capital
and so somebody like donald trump is
somebody who has who's rich in economic
capital poor and cultural capital and
therefore is never accepted into those
elite circles
so there's always kind of this struggle
between those who are
who have a lot of cultural capital to
sort of increase the relative
relative value of their cultural capital
versus economic capital
this is why a lot of people who are very
high in in cultural capital become
politically liberal um and and why they
tend to
see their fights as with like they're
fighting the billionaires on behalf of
the oppressed classes because they they
and the working class have
perceived themselves to have a common
enemy i think
social media is changing things because
on social media
there's where a lot of these status
competitions now take place
economic capital has been de-emphasized
especially on twitter which is kind of
the world that i'm most familiar with
for the most part you're if you're
arguing with somebody you have no idea
how much money they they have so there
are so you have to have other ways to be
able to show your status but the new
currency for distinguishing one um
for distinguishing one status versus the
next is through
um uh what i call moral capital which is
assuming these politic these these
elevated uh political positions um and
this uh this sort of moral posturing
what you know people
what people widely recognize as virtue
signaling um and uh and and and and as
social media has has sort of
taken over more and more of our lives
those status competitions have started
to bleed into the real world and um and
and have started to shape the real world
it's getting to the point where the real
world is a and it is an extension of the
debates that take place on twitter
not everybody on twitter is part of the
elite obviously but it is i think more
than other social media platforms it's
probably the the least populist it's the
one that is most
dominate where the culture is most
dominated by elites and i spend a lot of
time on twitter so i can't speak for
what it's like to not be on twitter but
i imagine that it must be really like
just
um
confusing because
you're out there never paying attention
to what's taking place on twitter and
then all of a sudden politicians are
talking about abolishing the police or
abolishing ice or you know all like
these like kind of ideas that seem very
radical and extreme and seem to come out
of nowhere
abolish ice started literally as this
twitter hashtag
and then aoc started talking about it
and then it became a thing and it was
like this started as a as as a twitter
intra-elite battle um over
um moral capital
and then it became you know an actual
public debate so the real world is is
being shaped by this stuff not the other
way around
[Music]